bienvenue à paroles autochtone si ces
milices à morlhon dupuis cette semaine
d'une question de ma non qui me demande
comment les autochtones sur vettel à
l'hiver avec le froid et les tempêtes de
neige maintenant on a développé plus
rien qu'une technique on avait la même
de l'hiver je pense j'ai vraiment à 100
parce que ça a été souvent je peux dire
ça a été au coeur de l'histoire du
québec
comment les premiers européens sont
arrivés et sont quasiment mort de froid
pareil pour la nouvelle angleterre
comment la ville qu'on connaît comme sa
place à jean zin failli mourir de faim
et même que la tradition d'un sphinx
giving de l'action de grâce américaine
tourne autour de l'hiver horrible que
les anglais ont passé donc le froid et
les premières nations c'était vraiment
une question de préparation mais aussi
d'observation de ton territoire où est
ce que tu vis qu'est ce que les animaux
font eux pour se protéger du froid et
quels sont les fourrures les cuire les
manières de se réchauffer qui sont
adaptés à ce territoire
donc c'est certain que on allait avoir
des mocassins quel être faits pour durer
l'hiver donc les mocassins échangeait
des auteurs plus tôt telle était plus le
mocassin était bon tout d'acheter plus
de délivrer à plus le mocassin allait
monter au dessus des genoux
un petit gamin en dessous du genou pour
éviter qu'un ange rentre on allait
porter de fourrure on allait doubler
avec de la mousse et surtout on allait
toujours s'assurer d'être au chaud ou de
ce cadeau au chaud et dans les
habitations faire enfin pouvait pas
nécessairement dire que tu as l'air
chaud parce que pour faire enfin il faut
faire qu'on va brûler beaucoup de boulot
et ça demande beaucoup d'oxygène donc
souvent il y avait des techniques qui
était pensé beaucoup plus pour créer de
la chaleur que pour faire du feu et on
avait des techniques de faire chauffer
des pierres dans les habitations qui l a
irradié de la chaleur sans créer une
perte d'oxygène ou justement besoin de
faire ventilé l'habitation où on allait
faire un feu à l'extérieur qu'ils
allaient envoyer la chaleur mais que
l'est
et tout les fumées allait rester à
l'extérieur et plein de technique de ce
genre ont été développés à travers le
territoire
on parle même de la terre de feu qui est
à l'extrême sud du continent
et ça ce qui avait le plus surpris c'est
que à l'époque les peuples autochtones
qui habitait en terre de feu se
promenait quasiment nue mais penser
constamment chauffer auprès d'eux fut
tellement que le feu était transporté
dans les canaux et c'est pour ceux qui
ont regardé la côte de la terre de feu
on aurait dit que la côte était en feu
et c'est quand les européens ont voulu
mettre des vêtements sur les communautés
autochtones que les gens commencent à
être malade parce qu'il pensait plus à
se réchauffer à se garder au sec
et c'est là que le froid commence à
apprendre mais il ya aussi le contact
avec les premiers virus européens sauf
que le froid c'était une chose qui était
dépendant du territoire haute fiabilité
et dont tu avais trouvé les trucs en
inspirant de la nature mais on est
encore là et même les longs hivers on
pouvait survivre en pensant à prendre
des tisanes puisqu'on avait pas les
légumes les fruits que les européens
avaient appréhendé dix ans que ce soit
du cèdre pour donner la vitamine c qui
fait qu' on n'a pas eu le secours but
comme certains des premiers arrivants au
québec mais on y va on se connaissait et
c'était en respectant le territoire en
s'adaptant à notre territoire et en
regardant ce que les animaux faisaient
parce qu'ils étaient les premiers à y
bien y vivre
donc merci beaucoup pour tag est sûr
maintenant j'espère que j'ai pu y
répondre mais il y aurait beaucoup
d'autres histoires que je pourrais te
raconter donc n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des questions à espace autre
acteur je vous souhaite une très belle
semaine